2018's God of War packed a lot of story
into its 20-hour campaign not only did
it have the Herculean task of
Reinventing the franchise's central
anti-hero Kratos but it had a whole new
world of myths and legends to introduce
Chief among them kratos's son atreus a
character whose secret identity will
play a large part in God of War Ragnarok
whether you played the original back in
2018 and won a story recap or you're
just here to prep yourself a Ragnarok
let's break down the story so far
God of War kicks off its Grand Narrative
of Gods and Monsters in a very human way
our Central anti-hero Kratos AKA The
Ghost of Sparta has relocated to the
Norse Wilderness far from his homeland
of Greece there he has settled down
married a woman named Faye and has had a
son that they call atreus we catch up
with him in somber circumstances Faye
has passed away and he's chopping a tree
marked by his dearly departed wife for
use as a funeral pyre his relationship
with his son atreus is somewhat strained
as well and the pair find themselves in
this tense dynamic as they set off to
complete Faye's last request to spread
her ashes atop the highest peak in all
the nine Realms their journey is cut
short before it even starts though by
the arrival of this heavily tattooed
stranger who doesn't mess about and goes
our Kratos into an epic fight to the
death and here I thought your kind
supposed to be so enlightened and so
much better than us either way Kratos
beats the ever living crap out of him
and that's saying something is he's
clearly Immortal but I'm getting ahead
of myself with the stranger dealt with
Kratos and a tria set out on their quest
to the top of the mountain on Route they
partake in a spot of hunting and land a
successful shot on this Porky little
fella only he's not just your common
Garden pig as this friendly neighborhood
witch points out when she forces the
pair to help her nurse him back to
health back at her house which it turns
out is a giant turtle the house that is
not the pig is he friendly once the pig
is revived the pair head on their merry
way and make it to the stunning fjords
of the lake of nine after sacrificing
his ax on the whim of some Ancient
Graffiti On A submerged Tower A lot
happened in a very short span of time
first the Lakes water drops a good 50
feet lower sending the pair on Norway's
most dangerous Whitewater rapid ride
before they encountered the largest
snake you will ever see
this turns out to be the world serpent a
giant snake supposedly big enough that
his whole body can wrap around the
entirety of midgard the realm of Mortals
with his giant body dislodged the lake
reveals a fair share of its underwater
secrets Chief among them the central
realm travel Temple and the nine realm
Towers hence the lake of nine name I
guess with an onward path cleared to the
mountain the pair head for the Foothills
bumping into not one but two charismatic
dwarfs on the way the pair named Brock
and syndra respectively turn out to be
estranged brothers who went their
separate ways when they disagreed on how
to run their blacksmith business but
you're not here for dwarf politics
you're here for huge mountains with
faces I guess yep that's the next site
the Kratos and atreus come across and
it's a site that presents something of a
problem for The Adventurous pair you see
the entrance to the mountain is blocked
by plumes of foul-smelling dark smoke
which is known as the black breath
fortunately though the witch pops back
up again to offer her advice on the
matter and directs Kratos in a trash is
to find and use the light of alfheim to
dispel the black breath
the temple needs time to wake up from
its long Slumber the trio travel to
Alpine but the witch is pulled back
through a portal to midgard for reasons
that aren't really made clear just yet
Kratos and atreus explore alfheim and
find themselves embroiled in a war
between the light and dark elves and
thankfully Chris eccleston's dower
version of Malachi there's nowhere to be
seen they eventually find the light of
alfheim and Kratos steps into it with
the bifrost held a loft to restore it
while he's in the light for what feels
like mere moments hours have passed back
outside where atreus has been holding
off an entire Army of dark elves with
kratos's ax atreus is naturally furious
with Kratos but he slowly thaws on the
subject when his father tells him he
felt like he was only gone for a short
time
so who do you think are the face in the
mountain
no better than I thanks
back at the mountain they use the
bifrost to dispel the black breath and
start their Ascent of the highest peak
in midgard on the way they encounter a
giant Lightning Dragon attacking
syndrome which Kratos slaves in a
grandstanding Showcase of bravado I mean
just get a load of this
[Music]
they reached the top of the mountain and
overhear a conversation between the
stranger from earlier who surprise
surprise turns out to be a Norse god
known as Boulder he's with his nephews
Modi and magni who are the sons of Thor
and they're chatting to the imprisoned
miramir another Norse legend about a
certain Marked Man traveling with a
child when the trio of gods take their
leave Kratos and atreus get chatting to
miramir and he informs the pair that
they've not reached the highest peak in
the nine Realms as it's actually located
in yotenheim he then pleads with Kratos
to free him from the torture he's been
living through for the past Century in
return for helping them get to their
destination which is currently locked
off to them by the Giants of jotenheim
Kratos agrees and miramir instructs him
to cut his head off and revive it using
old magic atreyus states that they know
which who dabbles in the old dark arts
and they hatch a plan to take mirmir's
disembodied head back to her
foreign
is so good to see you again I knew you
weren't dead when they reached the
witch's Turtle house thing she performs
the spell required to bring the head of
miramir back to life and he reveals her
as the goddess Freya however been a long
time you look well side note but these
Norse gods are far less flashy than
their Greek counterparts I mean just
look at these flamboyant I digress
Kratos immediately distrust Freya on
account of her being a god a feeling
that might have a little something to do
with his past Feud with the gods of
Olympus they leave and miramir informs
them they need to go and talk to the
world serpent who can help them access
yodonheim mimir blows on a big [ __ ] off
horn which is impressive seeing as he
has no lungs and after a quick chat with
the giant snake he points them in the
direction of a magic chisel that they
need to access the realm of the Giants
charting a course North mimir leads them
to yet another impressive sight the
Frozen corpse of thamer a giant who was
slain by the God of Thunder himself Thor
they access a chunk of the required
chisel but before they can make it back
to the lake of nine they're ambushed by
acne and Modi the aforementioned sons of
Thor after a tense fight Kratos
absolutely Slaughters magni sending his
brother Modi fleeing off into the tundra
cursing the Greek God's name
the boy's sick he needs Flair no
steady
[Music]
I'll be all right after their stunning
defeat of an Acer God even if he was a
minor one Kratos and atreus head to the
Temple of tear the Norse god of war to
locate the travel room to jonheim while
there they're attacked by a seething
Modi who pins Kratos down with lightning
coming to his father's Aid atreus
attempts to attack Modi which doesn't
really amount to much as he's a kid but
wait did you see that yeah atreus
briefly glows an angry red showing signs
of his father's Spartan rage only he has
no idea of the power lurking in his DNA
and Keels over in a coma as a result of
the power surging through his body
whoops plus they got broken meanwhile
Kratos Spartan rage is out for real and
overpowers Modi who scampers off whining
into the distance miramir senses the
DraStic situation and orders Kratos to
take the boy to Freya when they get
there Freya says that to save him she
needs the heart of a trial from the
Norse Realm of the Dead hellheim she
gives Kratos a word of warning though
his Frost Stacks will be as useless as a
chocolate teapot in the Frozen waste of
the Dead desperate to help his son
Kratos resigns himself to unearthing his
past and re-arming himself with his
iconic Blades of chaos a fiery relic of
his violent history which are hidden
back at his cabin he takes freya's boat
and takes an extremely reflective boat
ride back to the cabin so reflective
that his past literally manifests itself
in front of his eyes in the form of one
of his old tormentors Athena the Greek
goddess of wisdom Kratos forces her out
of his mind once he dones his iconic
blades and Begins the risky journey to
hell and back the bridge of the Damned
and there's the keeper making sure the
dead are really dead Kratos travels to
helheim slays the troll and rips its
heart out and just as he's about to turn
back towards midgard he's stopped in his
tracks by a sight that he's not seen for
well over a century he's confronted by
the giant face of his father Zeus who
lays down at him from the green Skies of
helheim
and flustered by the presence of his
long dead father kraysos inadvertently
Reveals His Greek Origins and miramir
recognizes him as the ghost of Sparta
I'm dangling from the hip of the bloody
Ghost of Sparta do not call me that as
they leave helheim mirmir implores
Kratos to tell his son the truth about
who he is when he wakes from his coma
and so it's with this heavy weight
hanging over him that Kratos returns to
Freya he hands over the trollha and the
Norse goddess revives atreus and on the
way out of the Witch's cave Kratos
finally tells atreus the truth behind
his Godly Origins alongside the fact
that atreus also possesses Godly Powers
although what they are remains uncertain
I wonder who else in a while
for sure rocking syndrome
with all that behind them the pair heads
back to tears Vault and after making it
past some traps that would confound even
Indiana Jones they secure the yoenheim
Rune marker as they Journey back up the
mountain to the gate to yonheim the news
that atreus is a god starts to fully
sink in and well it kind of goes to his
head the Arrogant little God uses his
Newfound sense of power to take revenge
on Modi by stabbing him in the neck and
kicking him off a cliff a reckless move
that does not go down well with his
father they make it back to the top of
the mountain bar ambushed by Boulder and
in the ensuing fight the gate to yonheim
is completely destroyed
Boulder kidnaps atreus and Kratos
follows in Pursuit by jumping right off
the mountain and onto a dragon wow where
the hell did that come from
the Fight Continues Atop The Dragon and
the trio end up in the depths of helheim
as they make their slow and steady way
back to midgard Kratos and atreus
witnessed Boulder having a vision of an
altercation with his mum who turns out
to be Freya they're arguing over a spell
that freyja has cast on Boulder an
allusion to the myth of freya's fear of
Border dying in the myth she goes around
and makes every living thing and well
quite a few not living things promise to
never kill or harm her son they all
promise as The Story Goes and hey ho
Boulder is Immortal the upshot of this
is he can't feel anything hence why he's
such an immoral crotchety bastard in the
game either way kratus and atreus make
it Out of Hell by flying yes flying an
ancient boat back to midgard it's a
little bit like that dirigible sequence
from The Mummy Returns only colder more
Scandinavian look clearly that tear
traveling somehow perhaps magically back
in the land of the living our Central
pair suss out that tier has found a
secret back door into yotnheim knowledge
that was passed on to him as a result of
his close alliance with the Giants turns
out this back door is actually an upside
down door found right beneath the realm
travel Temple and to access it all you
have to do is flip the whole Temple yep
Kratos does just that
and for his troubles finds the fabled
unity Stone which will allow the pair to
travel to the realm between Realms
Kratos and Co travel to this realm
between Realms via the game's fast
travel system which is accessed via the
branches of the igra seal tree the
sacred world tree from Norse mythology
after a leap of faith they find the
missing yonheim gate and restore it to
its place on the shores of the lake of
nine but there's some good and bad news
on the part of yonheim firstly the bad
news there's no travel Crystal which
means well they can't get there but
secondly the good news miramir can use
his eyes to act as the crystal if they
can find his second eye that is long
story short they deduced at the missing
eye is actually in the belly of the
world serpent because well of course it
is
is that you lost to us uh he thinks it
may still be in his stomach
um and he's open to letting you go into
his mouth to look inside all of which
leads them to the Mad situation of
having to canoe into a giant snake's
mouth which is the sort of thing you'll
only find in a god of war game they
retrieve miamis lost eye but on the way
out a throne from the snake's mouth to
the Frozen corpse of the giant thamer
where they encounter first Freya and
secondly her estranged son the absolute
Beast that is Boulder
[Music]
after a riotously violent fight Kratos
and atreus eventually overpower the Ace
of God when they learned that his
weakness is mistletoe a plant found in
one of atreus's arrows with his
immortality over Boulder finally takes
revenge on his mother by strangling her
but before he can commit matricide
Kratos steps in and does everyone a
favor by breaking the tattooed lad's
neck
[Music]
Freya u-turns from Near Death at the
hands of her own son to absolute
devastation at Boulder's demise in mere
seconds an emotional rollercoaster that
surprises atreus until it's pointed out
that any parent would mourn for their
child no matter how much of an [ __ ]
they are or were I guess Freya curses
traitos for his treachery and vows to
make him rot in hell but first she pops
off to bury her dearly departed little
God
listen the last thing you two need up
there's a decomposing the heat ruin in
the moment
but I'll wait for you here
between you and the boy
true with border consigned to the
cemetery of dead mythical Gods which is
actually getting quite full thanks to
Greater see my God of War timeline for
full details on that our two Lads and
their Godly head finally arrive at the
gates of joanheim but on their way to
the peak of the mountain they land upon
a treasure Trove of law courtesy of the
seemingly omniscient Giants including
Faye who it turns out was also a giant
yep they discover a giant Fresco on the
walls of a Mountaintop Temple that
basically foretells every last detail of
their Adventure not only that though the
stone tapestry spills the beans on two
Major Spoilers that have yet to pass
firstly atreus is referred to as Loki by
the Giants a name that Kratos confirms
when he reveals that that name was
Faye's first choice for the boy but
secondly Kratos and Kratos alone
Witnesses part of the Fresco hidden
behind a curtain that foretells of his
death which throws up another
tantalizing teaser for events to come in
Ragnarok and to be fair he's had a good
Innings at this stage so he's not too
too fast after all these Bombshells the
pair make their way to the peak and
finally scatter phase ashes as per her
final requests
[Music]
but wait there are still a few
Bombshells yet to be dropped firstly the
small matter of the arrival of thimble
winter which you probably haven't heard
of what you definitely have heard of is
what it leads to the cataclysmic end of
the Norse World Ragnarok thimble Winters
upon us boys the winner of the end all
winner secondly Upon returning home
Kratos and atreus lay their weary heads
down for a well-earned rest seemingly
they sleep for several years and when
they awake they are greeted by none
other than Thor himself who's come from
the Revenge of his two dead Sons
only several years haven't passed as the
pair awaken a second time with atreus
regaling his dream of Thor to his father
but with the rather ominous caveat that
it felt more like a prophecy which is
yet another juicy tease for God of War
Ragnarok
thanks a lot for watching this story
recap of God of War I hope you enjoyed
it and are like me looking forward to
seeing where the story goes next thanks
a lot for watching guys I'll see you
next time
[Music]